[MUSIC PLAYING]
- It's a very special moment
for me to address people
in Slovenia-English.
So I hope you
understand it anyway.
I've done about 100
concert tours worldwide,
and in 35 years of being a
conductor, probably thousands
of concerts.
But usually, I'm
turning that way.
Only when I do
things like Spixody.
So it's a very special
experience for me
to speak in English
to a general audience.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[END PLAYBACK]
- That's me with
different haircut.
Well, I'm very happy and very
honored to be here at Harvard.
And I really am--
I'm flying here, somehow,
from disparate perspectives.
How beautiful work I can do
here in good circumstance,
if sometimes I fly
with my kick scooter.
You know what I mean?
But basically,
what I'm doing here
is developing a few things.
As Meredith mentioned, I'm
developing a music theater
project based on something which
I'm going to tell you later.
It is named, called, BABA.
I'm also writing a book about
Choregie, concept and method.
And I'll also develop some other
projects, such as Stabat Mater,
which is inspired with
Mary of Incarnation,
and her "Letters to the Son."
I mean, I do more
projects simultaneously,
because that's the
way how I work.
But to give you some ideas what
this Choregie actually means,
I would like to share with
you a few previous productions
to understand how this new music
theater actually is developed.
So Choregie is a name which
somehow comes from Greek.
Old Greek tragedies and
chorics are supposed to be
[? patrons. ?]
And new music, which
is always together
with Choregie, new music
theater refers to new music,
which I usually perform.
And it's mostly music of our
time, contemporary music.
But sometimes, new
music is also something
which is rarely, or maybe even
never heard on our concert
stages, such as medieval
music, or maybe ethnical music,
or music which was taken for
some different context, such as
sociological or--
I don't know, maybe music
by women in monasteries,
or anything like that, which
are not usually at the concert
programs.
So the theater nowadays is
still very much perceived only
as drama theater.
So while Indian
theater, Kathakali,
or maybe Japanese theater--
Noh, for example-- are
structured from dance, music,
choral singing, stylized
rituals, and text,
the main characteristic of
Western theater is that content
is illustrated by drama--
acting.
But when people talk
about music theater,
we automatically think of
opera, operetta, or musical,
or music comedy.
So with years of working
with Carmina Slovenika
and Kebataola--
these are my two ensembles--
I developed a new
concept of music theater,
which is sometimes also
called vocal theater
or theater of voices.
What is Choregie nowadays?
It represents two fields--
concept of principles how to
create music theater projects,
and specific method of working
with ensembles, choirs,
orchestras, actors, conductors.
So for idea about
Choregie, I would like
to share with you one clip now.
It is one of my
earliest works named
"From Time Immemorial," which
was performed, for a change,
with opera--
chorus and opera, orchestra
and opera soloists--
which is quite a rare occasion
for music theater pieces,
because as you know,
opera houses tend
to keep their museums
with Verdi and Puccini.
And contemporary music is only
sometimes on the repertory,
just to be big.
So please-- "From
Time Immemorial."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So Choregie is composed of
elements that do not illustrate
or double each other.
So they somehow preserve
their own identity,
and do not rely on
convention or hierarchy
of elements in theater.
I can explain this like
that-- if you have a dish,
like a piece of meat,
maybe, and music,
and you can put some side dishes
as a garnish, a little bit
of vegetables-- that light, a
little bit of potato costumes.
That's the way how, very
often, music theater projects
are conceived.
So we have like a major
thing, or maybe in drama,
you have texts, and then you
add movement, or whatever.
But for Choregie,
it is important
that all elements are equal.
So we don't have a main
dish and side dishes.
In music, the score is in
direct control of the musician.
So the reception of the
execution of a music piece
depends only on
musician initiatives.
But this doesn't apply for
music in Choregie gear projects,
because this music
requires from musician
and the audience a completely
different experience--
namely, the intensive radiation
of heard music or word
is complemented with
culture of the scene--
the culture of the eye, the
feeling of external form.
So music becomes interesting
in a different way
as it gets these references
in non-musical world.
Why I'm telling this?
Because this music
was not composed
to be performed in opera, or to
be performed as a staged music.
It's concert music,
which is staged.
That's why this adding
of other elements
gives the music
different dimension.
Another thing which is
interesting for Choregie
is that performers are a
little bit different than we
used to have them in opera.
They used to use different
vocal techniques, not only
Bel Canto, also ethnical,
extended vocal techniques.
Musicians can be different.
Another aspect for Choregie
is that we perform it
not only in opera houses
and concert halls,
but also in industrial
halls, in monasteries,
in completely different
sociological environments.
I think for me, Choregie is
a really, really good field
and place for exploration.
And it's a playground
for researching new music
and new theater expressions.
So I would like to make clear--
Choregie, or music, new
music theater is not--
is not opera, is not
musical, and is not operetta.
So how did all this started?
I was conductor of
Carmina Slovenica
Ensemble and some others for--
Meredith already
mentioned-- for many years.
We did a lot of
competitions, concert tours.
And I start to add some other
elements to my performances.
And I actually start to use
movement as a first element.
Because in ethnical
music, in folk,
folklore music, movement
and singing and instruments
are so naturally connected.
And it was the first
contact with me
how to change this classical
formation of choirs
who were always kind of relics
of past, who stand in four rows
into something
more communicative.
So first thing was ethnical
music and movement.
And second thing was, of
course, Greek tragedy,
and the role of choir
in Greek tragedy,
where chorus was about 20
to 50 people, of 20 people
performers.
They sing.
They recite.
They move.
So they were part of the
performance, can make comments,
who was the mirror
to the audience.
And above all, they
serve as one entity.
It was not a group
of many people,
but they become one personality.
So there were my two
first inspirations.
And one of the
first such projects
where movement was
incorporated into music,
which is kind of ethnical
or new-age ethnical,
was "Adiemus," which we
can see a little bit of it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SINGING - "KAYAMA"]
[END PLAYBACK]
A little bit weak, because
it's very old recording.
But I would like to add
that this orchestra behind
is international
orchestra, consists of
only female, young
girls from entire region
in central Europe.
Because I was very much
inspired with [? Hospidalya ?]
[? Veneziane. ?]
I don't know if you're
familiar with this--
that in old Venice there were
charitable institutions where
they have female orchestras,
girls' orchestras,
and girls' choirs,
who were there,
who were abandoned children--
those who don't have parents--
orphans.
So I was inspired with these.
That's why we actually
established this formation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SINGING - "KAYAMA"]
[END PLAYBACK]
Another very important
thing in my work
is collective experience.
Because it seems
that these crowds
carry in themselves a
power and characteristics
which by far exceed the mere sum
of psychological and physical
characteristics of
individuals in it.
As you can see, I always
work with big groups.
But the voice of the
collective we really like best
is the voice of choir.
Because choir is the only
bigger group activity
that is not driven by any
ideology or economical,
political, military,
or religion reasons.
So choir is really a special
formation of human activity.
And I am very fascinated
about one voice who
becomes part of this
body of other voices,
or all these bodies
together which become
one body and one entity only.
So choir has a very special
role and special power.
Of course, it's
also very difficult
to work with the choir,
because there are
so many different characters.
And you really have to work
a lot on team building.
But at the end, when you manage
the established ensemble, which
is a really strong
organism, then it really
speaks very loud.
So I would like
to share with you
"Raua," just for a impression
of power of collective.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
I would just like to add that--
[END PLAYBACK]
--they are singing
without being conducted.
That's the very, very,
very special thing,
to have 50 people being
so tuned emotionally
and musically that they can
perform this complex music
without being conducted.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Thank you.
And the third very important
thing is, of course, voice.
Because voice is always
center of my exploration.
And voice in the
performance is impersonated,
and really becomes a very,
very important manifestation.
Actually, for me, it
becomes personality or more
personalities.
So I think that voice
has a special power
to link to some specter of
emotions which we are not
even aware that we carry in us.
Some psycho-analytical
language is
established when voices
make these soundscapes,
and control the stage.
But to understand the
voice better, of course,
you need to research it, to
make a voice laboratorium,
to really work on
every aspect of voice--
not only of beauty of the voice
like Bel Canto is, but also
extended vocal
techniques to learn
how other cultures use a
voice, from Eskimos to Balkan.
So there are different ways
how you place your voice.
But not only how to sing,
but also how to scream,
cry, and all kind
of uses of voices.
That's a really big
laboratorium which never ends.
Maybe we can see Prasonata, just
a little bit how we actually--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INTERPOSING VOICES] how
we orchestrate sound poetry
as a [INTERPOSING VOICES].
- [SPEAKING SOUNDS]
[END PLAYBACK]
- So that was example of
sound poetry, actually.
So how Choregie
projects are conceived--
about process a little bit--
the creation of
making these scores
brings musical notion of
composing to all aspects.
How we conceive of the piece,
how we perform it, of course,
and stage it.
So in Choregie, one
meta composition
is created by positioning
different music, text, drama,
and all kinds of visual elements
into one bigger composition.
So treatment of all these voice,
text, movement, light, image,
sound, gesture, and
all the elements
of theatrical production is
based on musical principles
and compositional techniques.
That means that musical
thinking actually
applies to the performance as
a whole, not only to music,
as somebody would think.
That's why relations
between elements
is, let's say
musical vocabulary--
polyphonic, imitation,
monophonic, homophonic,
polyrhythmic, polytonal.
So this musical thinking
is part of the process.
Somehow, I can say that Choregie
is performance in no man's
world, because it's
not the world of music,
or world of drama, or dance.
It's kind of adventure,
scenic adventure.
Sometimes musicians ask
me if music is not enough,
why do we stage it?
We don't stage any music.
When I get a score
or musical idea,
I start to think
simultaneously--
visual things, whatever
is part of the project.
And if other elements
are organically here,
then I go for Choregie project.
If they're not here,
we do a concert,
classical concert in a
hall, beautifully dressed,
and normal thing.
But contemporary
music, early music--
they are very inspirative
for other elements
to be part of the production.
So I think that music becomes
interesting in other ways
when it gets these references
in non-musical world.
So inside of this field, when
music and non-music meets,
then some different
dialogue starts.
And because music and non-music,
they have different meanings,
and coexistence somehow
brings new, third meaning,
which is actually what
I'm interested in.
But Choregie project--
that doesn't bring story
in classical sense.
So there is no
dominant story as we
are used to have it in
opera, operetta, and musical.
Of course, there is some
theme which was inspiration,
but we don't have this
classical protagonist
as we have it in opera.
And there is no drama
between two protagonists.
Nobody's killing, and
nobody's dying here.
So there is no--
dramatic is not-- we
don't get this dramatic
from classical acting,
but from the way how
music and other
elements are performed,
and how they are understood.
That's this dramatic
element, not the story
and relationships.
And we don't really have
some major protagonist
who get all the attention
of the audience, what
he's going to do.
Usually, the main
protagonist is chorus.
Even if there are five
people, a chamber group,
they are not individuals.
They are some part
of collective.
That's why I mentioned that
collective is very important.
So drama theater-- uh-huh.
OK, how do I conceive
these things?
As I mentioned, I develop
all elements simultaneously.
So for example, for my project
which I'm developing here,
I already make some paintings.
Because these are basis
for visual elements.
I already think how is
going to be set design,
how is going to be movement.
So all elements are
organically developed together.
It's not only music, and
then, OK, now we know music--
huh, what can we do?
Shall we put some blue light?
No, because light I understand
not as a source for light
to be seen, but as a message.
So all elements are
part of the score.
Is that clear?
Yes, cool.
So ideas-- what's first?
Sometimes, it's
a piece of music.
some question which
I channel, which
I carry in myself,
and I don't quite understand it.
Usually, these are questions
which I don't understand.
And as I have like
50 projects, I
don't really understand
much things in the world.
But I like to do
things which don't
have only one direct meaning.
So I like to have
this open field
for different interpretation
and for different receptions.
So it's very challenging
to bring familiar things
in new dress, and
in the new context,
and give audiences and
performance as well a chance
to interpret how they want,
which is somehow a big freedom,
but as well, also,
big responsibility--
to have this chance to
decide how to understand
the piece, the project.
So it seems exciting to allow
these familiar materials
on which Choregie is
built the possibility
to be discovered in new
ways again and again,
and in new perspectives,
in various levels, and even
various layers.
You can always find,
and always uncover.
So for example, here is
one piece-- just wait--
Placebo, or Is There
One Who Would not Weep.
This piece was based on very
well-known work Stabat Mater
by Pergolesi,
Baroque composer, one
of the most beautiful,
beautiful pieces in the history.
And is based on medieval
texts about Mary,
who is crying under
the cross when
her son, Jesus, was crucified--
so very well-known
medieval text.
What we did is we made
new orchestration.
So we don't have a
string orchestra,
but we have one accordion,
and cello player,
which is different
acoustical environment.
And we re-question,
actually, mother Mary more
than the situation of her
suffering below a cross.
We question Mother Mary
as a social construct,
and as an instrument of
supervision and control,
or Mary as a symbolic construct
in which femininity is confined
within the limits of
maternal, or Mother
Mary as an object
of imaginary love,
as a substitute of
suppressed male libido.
So the Stabat Mater
which is so well known
was somehow in new dress.
Please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- What is-- what is it to call?
- Some-- on the one hand,
some non-believer will say,
just calling.
That's mentioning a
name, just calling.
That's a call.
Others will say, well,
the fact that I called--
- [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
- Well, I don't go to church on
Sunday, don't get on my knees
to pray, don't memorize
the books of the Bible.
I got my own special way.
Well, I know Jesus loves me
maybe just a little bit more.
I've fallen on my
knees every Sunday
at Ghirardelli's candy Store.
[END PLAYBACK]
- Another project, which
was quite interesting,
because it happened just in
the moment of this Charlie
Hebdo and all this interesting
historical moments,
was "Toxic Psalms,"
where we research,
again, this collective
operation, and especially
what happens when collective
gets infected with ideology.
So through the research
of Hannah Arendt,
and her observations
in Jerusalem,
and similar experiments,
such as Milgram experiment,
and Lucifer effect, and all
kind of banality of evil,
we brought a project
which was actually somehow
a reflection of Palestine,
Syria, Pussy Riots,
and all these situations around
the world where religion is
becoming the main reason of
murderous violence in today's
world.
So it was kind of reflection
of human brutality,
and man killing for the
glory of their Psalms.
I never want to be agitator.
We have to do something.
I don't like this role.
But again, the message was
that we probably should not
be hiding behind a big Other.
So that's "Toxic Psalms."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Actually, this was
premiered in New York.
That's American premiere.
While this is running,
music was very
diverse, from Rachmaninoff,
to contemporary music
from Nordic countries,
to some early music,
even medieval polyphony.
So it was very, let's
say, eclectic musically.
- So I'll tell you everything.
Now, Sid [INAUDIBLE] one
of us, but he is also--
you know.
You can tell, right?
Right?
You can tell.
But sometimes, you can't tell.
You think someone's one of
us, but then they got to him,
and he wasn't anymore.
And then we got to him,
and he was one of us again.
But still, he has to look like
he isn't, that is, like he
already looks like he is.
But then they got wise to him.
And now he isn't again and he
has to look like he isn't, or
we'll get wise.
And that [INAUDIBLE].
[CHORUS SINGING]
- Please continue.
[SINGING]
The experiment requires
that you continue.
[SINGING]
It is absolutely essential
that you continue.
[SINGING]
- Thank you.
[END PLAYBACK]
As I told you, I am very
interested in early music,
and of course in
contemporary music.
And I found one
interesting French medieval
Gesamtkunstwerk,
actually, the first one
in history, "Roman de Fauvel."
The story is about a very
ambitious ass, horse,
who was very greedy, and has
all these terrible, terrible
characteristics--
egotism, hedonism, hypocrisy,
and all this kind of sin,
and corruption.
And this-- Fauvel is his name--
was the piece which was staged
in Basel opera, Basel Theater.
And it was kind of
transparent curtain
behind listeners can follow
events from this 14th century.
But I think everybody
was aware that it was not
the right time of the action.
Because this Fauvel
was serving kind
of as a metaphor for
actual political happening
across Atlantic, from
European perspective.
"Fauvel."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CHORUS SPEAKING]
[SINGING]
OK, so I hope that you get a
little bit of impression what
Choregie is, or
how deep love can
be to the choirs,
and this big love,
and can be also very
problematical love.
Because it's always
a lot of people
with different characters,
with different problems.
So it's a very
special work to work
with these big groups,
especially when you
work on contemporary music,
which is not easy to study.
And early music is also
difficult to memorize
and to digest.
But I think that when things
are studied and done, then
it gives a really
special experience.
And I really like doing it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]